[Music]
can you tell us what happened last night
I was leaving subway and then I came out
and I had my Bernie shirt on and I know
that as a man and a Bernie Sanders
supporter I'm the target
I saw two figures coming to me I could
tell that they were females and they
stuck out my mind stable that headdress
is on Native American headdresses and
then they threw what I imagine is acid
on me I don't know what this is this is
a liquid
it smells like cold brew I think it
could be a chemical one of them threw
feathers in my I couldn't see then the
other one put it a dreamcatcher around
my neck and tried to trouble you with it
like this I I've submitted to the police
I'm gonna give them my phone they can't
go through my tinder and go through
every woman that hasn't messaged me back
in six months I think they're all
suspects your candidate is a [ __ ]
psycho and this is who they're following
they're following a woman who doesn't
care as soon as I saw those headdresses
I knew I knew I was [ __ ] cuz those
headdresses and that worin shirt that's
like a Klan hood to me there was a lot
of Yas Queen and slay [ __ ] but spelled
KW EE and that's the way they were
pronouncing it
I like the Queen of England I think
anyone can be queen that's royalty
that's class based society that [ __ ]
doesn't work doesn't work I'm sorry I'm
getting good a lot of people think
because we need insulin were weak we're
not weak this whole thing it makes me
that much stronger makes me work a
little bit harder makes me that much
wiser so thanks for making me a fighter
[Applause]